in today's video we'll be explaining all
female titans in attack on titan we will
start with annie leonhardt and in the
later parts of the video we will be
showing you some of the female titans
that you probably didn't know about the
female titan is not so special if
compared to other titan shifters but
thanks to andy leonhardt and her
incredible martial arts skills it's
actually one of the strongest titans in
the anime on top of that the abilities
such as the scream the hardening as well
as the power to crystallize her human
form proved to be very effective and
useful in titan fights annie was
deported to an internment zone and later
adopted by mr leonhardt because her
blood test revealed that she was the
subject of ymir at some point in her
childhood annie joined the merlin
military as a warrior candidate meeting
comrades such as bertolt hoover reiner
braun and marcel galliard annie was
praised as impeccable for her fighting
abilities and was later chosen as one of
seven promising candidates to inherit
the power of the titans she was later
granted the power of the female titan in
accordance with her stellar combat
skills annie was selected as one of the
four warriors to carry out the paradise
island mission along with the jaw
armored and colossus titans the
objective of the mission was to attack
the aldians living in the walls and lure
out and steal the founding titan after
infiltrating the walls she joins the
104th training corps where she proves to
be a formidable fighter even in her
human form she ranks fourth among her
entire training class while posing as a
recruit on paradise island's city
defenses roughly on par with mikasa
annie is especially adept at taking down
larger stronger opponents either in
hand-to-hand combat or using the
vertical maneuvering equipment she is
able to trigger her transformation by
self-inducing pain usually by a hidden
blade concealed in a ring or by simply
biting her hand thanks to her hard
training annie is stronger and faster
than most titan shifters and is able to
maintain the form much longer before
reverting to her human state from
exhaustion on top of her extraordinary
endurance speed and strength annie
possesses the fast healing ability that
she can focus on specific parts of her
damaged body while other titans need to
slowly heal all their body parts
simultaneously one of her most useful
abilities is to crystallize her entire
body into a rock hard form so that she
can avoid being taken by the enemies
when aaron is revealed as the titan and
57th expedition of the survey corps
started annie uses her female titan form
to lead a group of titans to capture
aaron wiping out the majority of the
spotters on the right side of the survey
core's formation annie is eventually
lured into a trap in which her movements
are halted by the special
titan-restraining weapon she manages to
cover her nape with her hands forcing
irwin and his soldiers to search for
ways to destroy them constant
provocations by levi cause her to let
out a roar that causes multiple titans
to converge on her position the titans
devour her female titan form allowing
annie to escape from her titan
undetected catching up to aaron she
kills levi's entire squad and forces
aaron to transform the two begin a
brutal fight using hand-to-hand combat
techniques at the end of which annie
succeeds in defeating aaron's titan form
by decapitating it she captures aaron
inside the mouth of her female titan and
begins to flee but is later stopped by
levi sometime later she is discovered as
a female titan by armin who tries to
lure her into a trap accepting that she
has been found out annie smiles in
relief and transforms into her female
titan form killing those restraining her
in the process aaron then transforms
into his titan form to face her during
their battle they destroy everything
that comes in their way annie then takes
flight towards walshina but ends up
captured by the survey corps
apart from andy steiten we barely got to
learn anything about the other female
titans in history in the chapter about
king fritz and ymir's past we learned
about the first ever nine titan shifters
the first ever female titan actually
looked very similar to annie's female
titan the only clear difference is long
brown hair our next encounter with past
female titan shifters happened in the
middle of the battle of heaven and earth
when aaron uses his founding titan
abilities to bring all past titan
shifters back to life the first one we
see and surely one of the scariest
titans in the entire show is the
completely red female titan with long
dark hair this one looks very scary and
its skin kinda reminds me of a colossal
titan the next female titan we see
engages in the battle with reiner's
armored titan there's nothing special
about this one it looks very similar to
annie's version the only difference is
brown hair we also get to see what
appears to be the first ever female
titan battling tom savers beast titan a
few more female titans appear during
this battle but they are very low
quality so we weren't able to draw them
now that you know about all the female
titans in the show click on this video
to learn more about all attack titans in
attack on titan